una por una enmanuel macrón contempla
cada obra antes de dejar suelo francés
son 26 en total las que retornan de
vuelta bening una ceremonia histórica en
el museo que con ley de parís
presenciada por el presidente francés y
se esperó por estas obras durante mucho
tiempo mucho tiempo todos los jóvenes
necesitan apropiarse de la historia de
su país para poder construir mejor su
futuro para redescubrir también su poder
y a veces los misterios no hay razón
para que la juventud africana esté
condenada a no tener acceso a su
patrimonio cultural
estas obras son del reino de dahomey
actualmente conocido como benin en 2017
en burkina faso enmanuel macrón se
comprometió a devolver determinadas
obras a países de áfrica en un plazo de
cinco años un informe recomendó la
entrega de estos 26 objetos a benin el
ministro de relaciones exteriores del
país africano que llevó a parís para el
evento espera que esta restitución
impulse a otros a hacer lo mismo algunas
personas están seguras que pasar bien
cuando empecemos a enviar las sobras de
regreso a benin otros países van a decir
ok perfecto porque solo venir
porque no gabón egipto china todas
partes
las obras partirán definitivamente a
venir el 9 de noviembre el día que está
previsto que el presidente beninés
patrice talón visite parís luego serán
expuestas en distintos lugares
relacionados con la colonización antes
de que se inaugure un nuevo museo en
abomey en el sur de benin